so he's hawaiians away oh that's close
enough
[Laughter]
yeah I watch season three last night
coming here and it's pretty dark it's it
gets into the first episode you're just
like okay where's this going in its it's
a moment you see Matt that's just kind
of broken doesn't like God but it's it's
a very fantastic way to start off season
three well your impression when you
first watched it I haven't seen you
haven't seen it you've seen more than us
yeah we've seen the first three right
yes yeah we haven't seen anything no but
we were there you can talk about your
iconic white suit though I can what was
it like putting that on as the kingpin
it was very cool yeah yeah yeah it was
cool finding that with that with the
Wardrobe finding the the look of it and
the color of it and and you know the
type of white it was and they came up
with this a beautiful double silk
Italian thing oh my god and and then
putting it on I had to walk around the
show everybody at Deborah show Charlie
has a show it was pretty mad as well
when he had it on hair and makeup girls
on set when he first came on with there
was this moment you know where everyone
in the crew cast it cuz everyone's been
waiting for this moment it only came in
and he was wearing it and it was just so
iconic it was it was amazing wasn't said
think you got some wine on it too
did you get was it you got wine on yeah
you did yeah wasn't wine that's crazy
but it was a very weird thing can I tell
the story well can you play with Sue
word from shooting on this big round
table it's gonna be a fair that story
the table is big around there's a big
white thing and then something happens
like cancel your website give it away
and this guy hitting his head goes on
the table in this blood splatters right
right so there's no blood under the
table all the blood is on top of the
table and I'm sitting on the other end
of the table right now
so one trip travels all the way
underneath the table all the way to my
side and go to show and then dish and
then dish the whole thing just started
leaving in one spot all over my white
pants
and you didn't notice for a while and we
were like no and I got up and
everybody's like you're a part of the
team now and you're the FBI agent you're
the ones gonna cause a little bit of
trouble because you kind of help out the
kingpin here in the situation yeah I
mean like he doesn't know he's gonna be
causing any trouble I mean he thinks
he's doing the right thing and he thinks
that generally you know what his actions
are gonna help him help his family and
he's a family man and he's trying to do
everything to support his family and
give him the life but he unfortunately
he's finding a bit of financial
difficulty at moment and it's stopping
his progression through the FBI and
somehow he becomes Wilson Fisk's handler
and he comes up with this very tempting
offer where he will give me the names of
criminal organizations in return for a
good deal yeah it was a it was a good
deal is a good deal and but in turn he
doesn't under what kind of web he's
getting caught into yeah it's really I
hope everyone's I mean Eric did an
amazing job grace I mean he's did an
amazing job of everyone's ass yeah I
mean everyone's got their own amazing
storyline there no not but for me when
when I sat down Vera can you tell me
what was gonna happen with me it's
amazing it's so good really it's a good
character and sister Maggie plays a very
important role especially in the first
episode will we see a lot of
relationships with Matt in this in the
season yes yeah when they have a very I
mean she obviously cares deeply about
him she has a strong relationship with
them
and you know it's it's it's rich and
deep and
and goes a long way mm-hmm if Auggie's
relationship with that Wow
blossom you know I think with this
season Varghese obviously starting out
sort of dealing with some guilt feeling
like maybe he had something to do with
it you know he sort of starts to step
out on his own a little bit just as Matt
comes back and then you know screwing
everything up
who's your favorite superhero growing up
I was Punisher Captain America and
Batman
yeah that's DC Batman yeah
not lawful Batman not marbled at Marvel
Batman is punishing Punisher is like was
awesome for me and and and because of
Punisher derrida I met daredevil too so
I ran a couple of Daredevils but
basically Captain America Punisher and
the other guy yeah who's your favorite
Batman I'm just curious out of the
movies that have come out in the last um
I'm gonna say something really silly I
like them all I think they all do really
good jobs I'd like to uh what's the WASC
I did it Chris Oh Ben Affleck I thought
he was awesome it's awesome man and your
favorite superhero um Batman's always
been one of my favorite that's DC but
it's DC yeah we won't talk about him
yeah and I don't want younger I think
Captain America was boys yeah I remember
having a young a figure of Captain
America that was my only toy in my Shack
in Hawaii I went to good stalling I was
homeless have any superhero kind of
favorites I think I think I'd have to
say Betty Davis growing up was nice I
wasn't really a comic book guy I do like
like the Iron Man now it's a fun
yeah being part of the daredevil world
and for people who are going to be new
to this this series especially in season
3 how would you describe it the journey
fans will go through watching it it's
gonna be intense
I mean it's very it's it's I think it's
the most complex season of daredevil so
far I mean the complexities between
Eldon's character dabs and Charlie and
then this woman here coming into this I
mean it's like phenomenal and then well
kept of it and then the whole you know
that just a whole manipulation thing
that goes on between Jay and I and then
Wilson's character who comes in and you
know it's a very complex season a lot of
stuff goes on you're gonna love it
yeah it's gonna be a lot of holy moments
oh yeah holy cow holy cow holy cow
moments holy knowing that explosion went
off in the car yeah yeah no one really
in that trailer it looks alright but
like we don't realize how close to death
it was pretty intense
like after weekend Jung did that scene
this rush of heat get through yeah well
the car in front of us broke a little
bit too early yes right and we were -
were on it but no one knew the explosion
was gonna be so big so we're doing the
scene and the scene as he's talking
behind me and we like that and then this
explosion happens yeah and I remember
the explosion went off and I was like
it's really hot in a golf ball flames
yeah and then I'm like where's this car
it's a car one of us wake I'm full speed
no it can't see I can't see anything so
I remember my reaction is I grab
[Laughter]
both of our hands when it goes off I
remember when it finished everyone came
over and they were like I didn't any
explosion